oh um thanks everyone for being here on
a Sunday morning I appreciate it I'm a
logorithm practically it's just about
having to get up so early this morning
but now that I'm here everything is
great so we are indeed a charity and I
think that probably quite a few of you
have either heard of us so kind of dump
some stuff with us in the past actually
could I have a quick show Hansel's who
even knows what data kindness or who yay
okay so you guys can just get a room so
for the other ones here's the
presentation that we're going to we're
going to basically go through two
projects that we've run over I mean one
last year and one the year before and
then we're going to kind of give you
some insight into what why what we do
that it is that is a bit different from
the other kind of data science projects
that you may be used to in the profit in
a for-profit sector and what we're
really trying to achieve in the in the
charity sector and how we do that so so
this is who we are or at least a small
amount thereof so we're a non-profit and
the basic reason for us existing is that
we believe that the same techniques that
are used in the for-profit sector the
same algorithms that are used to
optimize click or to sell more stuff
that is not needed to people or to you
know I don't know ensure that the right
number of people get to the right place
at the right time all those algorithms
and techniques can actually be used in
the nonprofit sector as well and
actually they might be even more useful
there because of the the nature of the
kind of social complexity that those
sectors are often tackling the challenge
obviously is often a financial one for
charities because I know me indicate
charities are often mostly just you know
running on very tight funding they've
got very few volunteers and it's very
rare for them to have a data scientist
in-house now one of these social
organizations that we're going to be
giving you an example of actually does
happen to have a data scientist in-house
but that's an extremely pretty much
that's like a one-of thing that's never
occurred before otherwise so the the
charities that we work with they don't
have data centers in-house they don't
really know what data science is and
some of them I mean Muslim know what
data is but obviously that kind of level
of awareness is extremely kind of on a
broad spectrum and so it's um you know
those are people whose main kind of work
is really social work
so the they're kind of you know their
challenges are that often they don't
have real clue what what deta sons can
do for them so they're you know they're
sitting on extremely interesting data
but they don't really know how to how to
use it to solve the problems that
they're trying to solve and this is
where we come in so we're trying to
basically get together a lot of people
who are all pretty much all data
scientists although we cannot take
people who've got Moken project
managerial type roles usually and those
people come from all over the world so
we're definitely a global network we've
got six chapters we've got chapter in
Bangalore we've got one in Singapore
we've got one here in the UK and then
we've got three wait actually that's one
was that we've got Dublin as well and DC
San Francisco and then we've got HQ in
New York which is the kind of mothership
and we've got about honey we've got
hundreds of volunteers are all of whom
you know are kind of somewhat over on
the more ad hoc basis than others I mean
some of them kind of you know work with
us all the time our could kind of been
working with them like for about two
years now
I know kind of almost on a weekly basis
at the moment and then we've got people
who come in once in a while and all
those people are people who basically
are hopefully you know trying to find a
way to use their data skills for social
good which is something that maybe in
your day job you don't literally get to
do so if you work in finance then you
want to get yourself some camera points
you can come and work with that and if
you don't then you can also I mean it's
also a great kind of way to get people
involved in you know fulfilling that
what you're doing is actually making a
difference I mean I think there's a lot
of concern growing concerned about the
ethics of data science both really to
the data that we use the way that we
apply it the kind of algorithm bias that
is kind of becoming a law and a visual
problem a visible problem so you know if
you're going to want to feel like the
data center and the skills that you've
got actually contributing to solving
real problems then you know definitely
come in and work with us so the data
science that we do is somewhat of a
different data science that we that you
guys might be used to and I'm going to
assume that all of you here know what
their defense is and so I'm not going to
give you the kind of Venn diagram of
data science see things like you've all
seen SAS all of the time but essentially
the kind of data that we've got is off
not really what you would think of big
data actually it's often not even really
what you think of as medium data I'm not
sure whether level is now to be honest
and I don't think it's really relevant
actually what we've got is data that's
often quite small scale quite patchy and
more importantly is data for which you
can directly see those human problems
that the charities are trying to solve
so I'm going to give you after this an
example of an you know of work that we
did with center point to the
homelessness charity and and when you
look at this data you can see the
problems directly you can see the
numbers of homeless people you can see
what happened to them you can see why
they're homeless what happened into
their journey and and this is data that
is very I mean to me that that's kind of
what are the strengths of this data is
that you get involved with it and right
away you know that you're dealing with
real human problems and you can see that
it is you know very much kind of data
that's close to the people but obviously
that also means that you have extreme
kind of anonymization issues you need to
be extremely careful how you handle it
so it's data it needs to be handled with
care often small size very human data
and the science that we do is really the
science that you would think would be
the finest that any charity would
usually normal to do which is actually
try to test a hypothesis and try and
test the theory of change you know what
is the problem
I'm trying to solve in society is it you
know growing you know food poverty is it
homelessness is it you know domestic
violence and is the action or are the
actions that I'm taking having the right
effect so this kind of approach to kind
of classic I mean I guess basically the
scientific method it's not something
that most charities approach their work
with and often because they don't really
have the capacity or the kind of data to
assess this so often this is what we're
trying to do we're trying to help
charities understand whether the impact
that they're having is really the right
impact whether it's sufficient whether
they're using their resources in the
right way so it's it's really you know
science and hypothesis testing that has
forgo actual action plans that a charity
can put into place and and hopefully you
know be able to demonstrate that yes
what they're doing has a good impact and
has the right effect and therefore that
they can you know that that's something
that we use to get some funding as well
so something to keep them going and and
to kind of to help to hold up as proof
of their efficiency and so the events
that we run I'm just going to go through
extremely quickly here to give you an
idea of how we do all this
so we've got some community events that
we are going to do more and more awesome
and some of those community events are
basically you know cherry and I being
here and talking to you guys but and so
engaging with the data science community
but also a lot of events engaging with
the nonprofit community so it's always a
two pronged approach we are actually
holding some some kind of data science
and I'm office hours for charities where
they can just call in and say well you
know I've got those kind of issues I've
got this kind of data this kind of that
what can I do with it we do a lot of you
know kind of at how the data advice so
so we're really trying to grow a large
community that involves two groups that
very often don't really you know get to
meet each other then the details which
are probably the events that you're most
familiar with and so those data dives
are running they're kind of there's two
sides of data does the job itself which
takes place over weekend and that is
essentially a hackathon but I mean the
big difference for the hackathon is that
actually what we're trying to get out of
it is is a proper we're producible
usable and verifiable analysis or I mean
hopefully data science type of analysis
that that comes from the data that the
charity gave us all from the other that
we gather to try and solve the problem
that the charity is tackling and so
those data does is sometimes we're gonna
have something like I don't know two or
three different charities that actually
have a project on the day and then we
have maybe 80 to 100 volunteers showing
up and then everybody gets moved around
in different groups and then you get to
work on one aspect of a project for four
whole weekend and then those days are
headed by people that we call the data
ambassadors so both Charlie and I have
been data ambassadors on on projects and
so those people are on the day
essentially kind of conducting the
project and in conducting and helping
people work on the project over the
weekend but then they also work with the
charity for often I think it's I mean
absolute about two months before the
dive so that means making up for the
charity very regularly looking at the
data crunching it checking that the data
is clean which it's never in so that
there's a lot of data munging involve a
lot of data cleaning a lot of a lot of
kind of reassessment and readjustment of
expectations because very often like I
said the people that will work with a
lot they're not data science sadly
necessarily so they might have
completely
you you know over-the-top expectations
of what can be done you know you might
our charity that comes to us and say
well you know we just we just want to
solve world hunger you know can we do
that in two days with that no problem
you know so you kind of have to do a lot
of readjustments here and so that that's
kind of a fairly um you know heavy work
involved over for the period of about
two months and then you get to the dive
and hopefully the data is clean the
data's ready to go and you've decided
what it is that you were going to do
with it so it's very much kind of like a
consultancy type role but you you have
to work extremely closely with the
charity and we'll talk a bit about that
later as well
and then the data core projects are not
not completely dissimilar but the only
people who work on the ethical projects
are data ambassadors so we're going to
have often a team of two or three people
working together somebody who's going to
be more like a kind of data with to data
scientist and then and then the project
manager often and then those people are
going to be working on a weekly basis
with the charity to try and deliver
something that's kind of fairly you know
kind of kind of a daily I mean I hide
the word deliverable but essentially way
is what it is and so something that
actually can be the result of a project
so it can be you know a design it can be
an analysis or model that can be rerun
it can be something that's actually
implemented so some some action kind of
algorithm that is implemented in a
specific fashion that can be rerun and
we don't easily by the charity and those
take place over for two to six months so
those are fairly in-depth projects and
so they involve a little bit more actual
data science of on the part of the data
ambassadors than the data tapped out so
those are essentially the kind of three
ways that we try and solve those
problems and so what we're going to be
doing now is going through two different
projects that we've run and Charlie is
going to be showing you the first one
and we can explain to you exactly what
how those projects going to fit into the
grand design of what we do and then
we'll give you some some key insights
into the magic world of data science for
good so I'll leave the slice to Charlie
thanks Emma that means starting it up
thank you
yeah so I'm going to talk about a data
dive that happened with we farmers the
partner organization last September I
was a data ambassador for that so like I
said data dives are they run like
hackathons the tagline is their goal is
insights not apps that's catchy
they're really intensive very sociable
they're fueled on coffee and takeaways
and they're basically a lot of fun you
know it's really impressive what people
can achieve like you get a big group of
people in a room for a weekend they
bring loads of enthusiasm different
expertise different interests different
tools that they're really familiar with
and they're great oh I can't recommend
it enough you can sign up to one coming
on it's a lot of fun but so because
they're so intense they're short it's
really important that the data
ambassadors strategize carefully scope
the problem and decide how to milk
everything they can out of the
volunteers that do show up on that on
the weekend so we farm we form our text
message based forum for farmers in rural
countries they mainly operate in Kenya
also Uganda Peru and a couple of other
places rural farmers are a really
vulnerable group they have limited
access to information they often
operating a subsistence level with you
know so if like a damaged crop or a
disease in their livestock can be
literally life or death they don't have
access to information or finance but
they often have very resourceful
solutions to the kinds of problems that
they face so we farm is all about trying
to build a network so that people can
share that knowledge that they've built
up if they don't have access to the
Internet they can use this text-based
forum to communicate with each other and
share these solutions so this is roughly
how how it works
worked a farmer here's an advert they
text the platform saying I want to sign
up and they use a code corresponding to
the advert that they heard so either on
the radio in a newspaper and that tells
the system what language they prefer the
system then exchanges a series of
messages with them asking them questions
like what's your name your age your
gender are you a member of a co-op and
all these other things and they don't
necessarily
so you have quite sparse data about
specific users but they signed up once
they sent the initial text then if a
farmer has a question he texts that
question to the platform and it gets
automatically distributed to a random
selection of other users ideally from
the same co-op but not necessarily
that's not always possible so anywhere
between 10 and 100 people receive this
question sent out and if they have an
answer they reply to the system using a
prefects code and that answer is
automatically routed back to the person
that asked the question so that works
quite well in some cases but it does
lead to some user frustration we've got
some stories here that came out from the
dive so top left for example this guy
wants to quit he's desperate to quit
first he's too polite
it gets more formal and then he just
okay yes yeah it gets quite desperate
please please please PLEASE I want to
quit this one's interesting buy my pigs
so the guy wants to sell a pig he wants
to know what you can expect for it
it keeps asking he feels ignored
somebody responds with the name of Jane
but he has no way of contacting a person
that says who's Jane Jane is interested
in my Pig because you can't root a
question back to the answerer so he gets
in this loop basically gets really
increasingly frustrated that he can't
say his piggy wants Jane's mobile number
and eventually says how do you expect it
to be a way for members of yesterday
annoyed over here stile up Jane how do I
contact Tabitha so that's kind of an
interesting one
somebody's responded to a message that's
been signed off with the name Tabitha
nobody knows who Tabitha is because how
do I contact Tabitha message goes to a
new random sample of users so some
people suggest Facebook and then you get
these sassy answers like style up Jane
what sort of question you're asking
shame on you that's kind of also
interesting right because a fairly
common attempted use as a dating service
people people want like a loading hearts
thing this guy 23 and he delayed to
marry 19 to 26 who could I marry I've
got so many cows hooked me up man
so yeah so the fact that the platform is
limited to a single exchange of a
question and answer they are goes back
to the original question is that's kind
of an intrinsic feature and people get
frustrated with that so we want to
improve that and that was identified as
our main goal for the for the data type
so short of creating this this two-way
system that would require a complete
reengineering the whole platform so that
was beyond the scope right but we
decided that we could improve the user
experience by improving question routing
so trying to make sure that the question
is a good quality and that they go to
users who are likely to have an answer
for that question and that requires
understanding of the users so where they
are what they know about what they're
interested in and what you know what
their expertise is in also what
languages they speak of course that can
be often more than one and also an
understanding the question so what is
the question actually about and how good
is it
is it worth sending it out if it's just
something like who's Tabitha or yeah
where's my Pig etc and so we have this
two-pronged approach understanding the
users understanding the questions and
they will hopefully feed into each other
to improve question routing and this is
the data set that we prepared to where
we were lucky enough to have an in-house
data scientist that we form he helps us
through this but we want to scope it
quite carefully so we limited it to
messages users those tables are fairly
self-explanatory
we had about 64,000 users once we'd
filtered out only those in Kenya with
the preferred language of English and
Swahili and then the message is that
those users sent that was about 240,000
and the responses table is a bit more
complicated that's basically all
messages that were sent to or from the
system and who so if a question was sent
out to someone and no answer was
received that's still logged in the
responses table so on the user's there
was some some really good work on
analyzing usage patterns and trying to
detect frustration I'm not going to
explain
it's pretty complicated but basically we
have this user segmentation we're down
here we've got so on the X actors
questions answered on the why questions
asked so people who don't do either
lurkers people who ask a lot but don't
give any answers as a learner's gurus
are the ones a fount of knowledge and
then super users just absolutely lovely
from can't get enough so that's quite
useful and then look at the messages
again there was some really good work
trying to assess the quality of
questions that's enough to be really
quite difficult we look to message
length the how consistent the spelling
was how how well it translated to target
language what time of day it was sent
none of those things we correlated with
how many answers it was it received so
we kind of gave up on that but topic
analysis was quite successful we're just
going to do a quick demo avoid display
of a PI lva vis visualization so this
month thanks so I thought this was quite
brave up until jeans keynote yesterday
which was just one big demo it's amazing
I'm just going to mouse over so many
topics so if we look at yeah there's the
topic number one plant seed maize potato
when it's number three that's about
chickens and eggs and hands there you go
now you know which one comes first
haha that was about cows so that looks
like it's giving some meaningful results
so that's great I think how do we get
back to the do you want to go back to
this yeah
yeah
cool thanks so yeah and then we have a
little homemade emoji cloud which shows
the the main topics we identified
chickens are really important coops a
big livestock big corn that little poo
is fertilizer yet tomatoes so it's kind
of meaningful work we can see that
people are asking questions about
farming and they split we used to be
nice into topics so that's great and so
those two threads that plug together and
we have this this kind of prototype
that's just about put together in the
space of the weekend where the system
has a way of detecting the question
comes in its about chickens and the
system can now pick this guy up here he
is an expert on chickens he lives in the
next region but it's worth sending him
this question because he answers
everything about chickens these people
down here they're in the same region he
also likes chicken she's more into cows
but she answers a lot of questions and
this guy was nearby it's worth throwing
in the question and seeing if he has
anything and so yeah that was that was
what we called thanks
well yeah so that was an example of a
project that we did again had you know
kind of actually a fairly kind of
complicated set of questions and then
we're really when we started that we we
weren't really sure exactly what we were
going to be looking at but this was
split into a lot of different threads
and a lot of different groups were
working on different things that we then
pulled together the next project I'm
going to show you is is quite a
different one actually so this was what
sense point so center point is I think
probably most of you have heard of them
in they're quite well-known in London so
the UK's leading charity for homeless
young people they support over eight
hundred thousand five hundred young
homeless people young being defined as
sixteen to twenty five year olds all
over the UK they're their London centre
is very big they were also working in in
Yorkshire and your knowledge the North
East of England so they're really an
organization that tries to tackle the
issue of youth homelessness specifically
and and it is as you'll see a difficult
issue to tackle mostly because it's kind
of fairly unclear exactly what the scale
is and it's a hard issue to actually
define I mean homelessness generally is
hard to define because
as you can imagine a lot of it is
somewhat hidden so it's really hard to
get probably stats on it and then if you
don't have professors it's even harder
to do any any work any significant work
and so we've improved that your work is
having an impact
so the centerpoint team actually had a
data analyst in house and somebody who
was definitely very skilled in if not
daily science at least kind of data
analysis generally and data awareness
and I think actually the hold of
Centrepointe is a very you know at
Cinnabun is a very data we're charity so
that was a gun another project where we
kind of at least had part of our work
and have gone for us because we were
working with people who understood the
value of data and just I mean that
doesn't mean necessarily that the data
was with great quality but they
understood what it was that would be
needed and they also had because of
their kind of their work with difference
in the geographical locations you know
extremely kind of detailed knowledge of
stuff like what is a you know lower
super output area versus a super output
area they kind of understood all that
stuff so anyone who's kind of ever
worked with do Jason of the UK kind of
the UK second the UK geography will
realize that this is kind of a fairly
niche thing to know about in nomnom data
circle so it was really good to be
working with people who understood
exactly some nerdy stuff like this so
the main question that we had is how
many young people are facing
homelessness in the UK and this is
really a fairly simple question actually
it kind of became the one thing that we
worked on during the whole dis dive and
the the way that we went about testing
this question was to send out what Liz
sent upon had been sending out Freedom
of Information requests to every single
local authority in in England and gotten
about 50 of them 50 percent of them back
so that means that for about 50 percent
of the local authorities we had data on
the scale of homelessness in that local
authority and that kind of data was
dependent I mean it's in some local
authorities it was extremely well
prepared and extremely clear what it was
that they were referring to when someone
did you sent us a bunch of you know like
Word documents with a few kind of
numbers here in there that we couldn't
remake any sense out of so already even
on out of the 50 percent of data that we
had the data quality was was extremely
varied and the this kind of question how
many young people are facing
homelessness in UK is something that you
would
there will be a clear answer for and I
guess you maybe you wondering well why
didn't you even know but actually nobody
does know because that is I mean like I
said homelessness is in great part of
kind of hidden problem in society and
and the official figures do exist but we
had and I mean Centrepointe had already
kind of previously done some assessment
on this at least some kind of
small-scale basis and then you that it
would the official figures with nowhere
near the actual scale of the problem and
to give you an idea of just how
difficult it is to actually get a proper
vision of what's going on in with a
problem of homelessness in UK so this is
pretty complicated but actually really
well done graphics that Centrepointe
come up with and all those question
marks there's a clickable point anything
does it work Yes No
so all question marks are areas where
basically so you have a young person to
start the trajectory and they can be
routed through you know a dozen
different routes and then asked about
you know all the points during the
projectory essentially they can just
going to be lost so they'll be lost I
mean the kind of most obvious one is the
one in the beginning where somebody's
homeless but they might not ask for help
or nobody might actually register that
they're homeless so those people are
lost already because they never were on
the grid and then you get lost because
you actually get real house but then you
you know you maybe you feel kind of like
relapsed and actually nobody's nobody's
tracked this if you go all the way out
to the the kind of assess under the
Children's Act which which is something
that is going to happen to you if you're
if you're over kind of like a younger
age then you will actually potentially
not be you know not be helped oh you
you'll be found to be in need of health
but send home with support and then we
don't know whether it actually worked or
not so there's also a lot of actions
that are kind of semi actions when you
go okay well you just go and do this and
then people just forget about you and
you'll just you're off the grid again
and then there are all those other
question marks here where basically
they're kind of the only way to get
properly housed if you're a few adult is
to be eligible and to be qualified as in
ten unintentionally homeless and in
priority need and then you'll be a tree
house anything else will not be we asked
and so those people all of those people
there so
eligible employers need and homeless but
intentionally so which is a very kind of
perverse way of describing homelessness
because it was intentionally homeless
but that essentially means people who
kind of who extremely hard circumstances
had to leave their home they just
couldn't live there and so for for
whatever kind of social reasons and that
means that you that was your choice so
therefore we're not rehearsing you
eligible homeless but not in priority
need so you're homeless but it's not
priority need so I mean that could mean
a lot of things and again like the way
that people are on the local authority
kind of you know that in local
authorities will assess that that
priority need level or that's kind of
intentionally unintentionally homeless
kind of you know classification those
are very kind of human decisions to make
so it's not even like this is a kind of
clean justification there's no way to
really tell whether that was done
properly and then is this all of the
eligible people and so that can cover a
lot of people so there's there's all
those question marks here and there and
and the figures that we do have that are
the official figures they're only
covering the things that were track so
you can imagine that really that there's
no way that this kind of this figure
they're actually kind of corresponds to
to the reality of the problem so what we
did is that we so we got like I said
about fifty percent of the data that we
wanted and even within that fifty
percent there were some holes and there
was some clarity and there was a lot of
stuff that just didn't make any sense so
we had to go back to the to the local
origins to hang on a minute dad Armitage
doesn't seem right what's going on with
this and but overall the the kind of the
main problem actually was to just impute
the missing local authority numbers from
the ones that we did have which
essentially turned into a massive
project of good ol multivariate
regression which we ran on every factor
that we could think of and this is when
we started plugging any other kind of
demographic data sets that we could find
so went to the ons who went to were very
important to whatever other kind of
research that we could get that were
describing the kind of basic demographic
characteristics of the local authorities
that we were missing as well as the ones
that we weren't and trying you know see
if we could do some imputation there so
those are kind of fairly actually those
are probably not the best end of the
most predictive
cherry stick that we got but this gives
you I mean we have no no no like
thousand two thousand dollars and and so
what we found was that they were there
were a few you know a few things that
were tended to collect fairly well with
with hope with a high number of homeless
people so actually one of the like one
of the second most high the second
highest correlation that we had with
whether a local authority had a high
number of young homeless people was how
many vacant dwellings they were which is
amazing it hurts if you think about it
because that basically means that the
more empty houses there are in a council
the more likely they are to have a lot
of people who don't have some asleep
which you know it's just beautiful and
then the most highly correlated the most
highly correlated factor that we had
with you with homelessness and was the
number of homes sold through the right
to buy scheme so again you know kind of
a fairly interesting insight into the
way that the kind of general kind of
social politics actually working you
okay we're actually there is a housing
stock and council will get rid of them
somehow for the right to buy scheme so
you will buy your housing you will buy
your you cancel flat essentially and
that is no longer a council flats
available as you know somewhere that
people can be relocated so a council
that's got a high number of homes sold
for the right to buy scheme is also
likely to have a high number of homeless
people so we found a lot of very
interesting somewhat controversial stuff
in that data so that was kind of a
really just just for that only that was
a really interesting project because it
was really you know it was kind of quite
hard to kind of look at this and not
think why not what is going on here you
know there was a lot of weird stuff so
this is what we had in the beginning and
so we kind of concentrated on the
English England area only actually
because as you can see and I kind of
cropped it off actually Scotland was
just perfect they had everything mapped
out they had all the data they returned
everything they were great if there's
any Scottish people there
thank you it was just honestly I was
kind of blown away at just how different
the the policy of a entering from
information request wasn't gotten and be
how well their data was you know how
much of a kind of strong will do was to
actually get a map out and interact
those things extremely rigorous later
that was great so we really concentrated
on trying to get the data for the
missing regions in England which you can
see are many
and so what we ended up with was this
which means we filled a whole array and
so all all those consoles that were the
local authorities that were missing we
imputed it so from all the variables
that we had on this local authority and
we basically got to to an estimate
number that was this so the official
figure was 13,000 so they it was
estimated by the government but they
were 13 thousand young people who were
homelessness who who a homeless or any
okay and our provisional findings we're
90 thousand so that was actually the
over eight times as many young people
ask for help because they are homeless
then the number accepted as statutory
homeless so that was those were our
findings at the end of the data does and
then what we did after the days of is
that we cannot carried on with the works
because the you know it had been kind of
fairly difficult because we had a lot of
data crunching and managing to do during
the die so we didn't have time to
actually finish the analysis as well as
we wanted so we did a kind of fairly
simple regression that came up with a
ninety thousand number and then posted
as a few of our data scientists or
volunteer data scientists carried on
working with the model and we find it a
little bit and kind of took a slack
slightly less kinda naive approach to
actual kind of coefficients and you know
basically to try to understand whether
actually the council's that had not
responded had kind of somewhat different
characteristics because of the fact that
they had not responded to the ones that
did respond and so they weren't a bit
further into the kind of statistical
analysis of all the demographic data
there and came up with that number which
is significantly higher which is 136,000
so this is the number where at the
moment or at least that was out of last
year we stood and Centrepointe has been
using this number a lot both to kind of
demonstrate the need of a you know over
an extremely kind of strong response to
youth homelessness which is rising and
also to you know to kind of demonstrate
how useful it is to you know to kind of
use this data to really look at because
all of this data is free data I mean
this is data you can Freedom of
Information request any of you can find
one all the data we use was public data
so so this is really a project that was
actually in theory you could have just
been done by absolutely anyone you know
so this is also project that really
helped us to
trait the use of open data and the use
of you know just kind of using all all
over the data sets to try and solve the
real a real problem and answer a real
question and you know if you think about
it actually if the government had wanted
from the beginning to get a good idea of
how many people were homeless they could
have actually done all that work and
gotten to that point right so so this is
obviously this is where the you know the
kind of the NGO sector kind of jumps in
and goes okay well this is what we do
when we're gonna try and you know and
kind of fill in the blanks and try and
do all the work that should be done by
the authorities but I'm actually being
followed up with and so this you know
this kind of results led to quite a lot
of publications it led to a lot of of
press for for Centrepointe and food do
kind of general coverage of the issue in
UK and yeah so this was overall what
kind of really successful this live and
it was an interesting one because we did
in the end just that was that that
number really was the single result that
we got out of it and well it wasn't a
single result actually because what we
mean the map was also a result and
obviously that was a data base that we
then built up and you know so they had
more data to work with but it was a very
simple problem and quite unlike that we
found one where where you kind of had to
do a lot of rebooting and thinking about
who was answering what and what they
were saying what it meant and where they
were and when they were answering and
all that kind of complicated Network
stuff actually this was fairly
straightforward but it's it's it's also
very useful and so that's kind of
another another side of the data
analysis that we do so so yeah so this
was the second project I wanted to show
you and we're not going to be showing
you some or sharing with you some
insights from from their sense of it
thanks yeah yeah so I'm just going to
give an overview of some of the three
lessons learned from working with
charities and how it's slightly
different from working in a commercial
sector and so first of all finding
problems can be harder than finding
solutions so this is a bit frustrating
actually a good cause doesn't
necessarily amount to a good project and
that the big organization is a lot of
funding who you might expect to have the
expertise and not always the ones with
whom you can construct a well scoped
project and the size of the data doesn't
matter
big data small data we just need
relevant data and that's not always
available and when a charity approaches
us and we can't find a project with them
we have a data maturity framework that
we try and point them towards and that
was developed with Nesta the innovation
foundation that is designed to help them
kind of think about where they're
lacking and how they could improve their
expertise in their awareness of their
data usage lots of charities want help
with marketing and that's boring so we
have like a blanket no policy on on any
kind of like targeting of fundraising
and yet scoping the problem can be
really difficult as Emma said like we
want to predict the future or find
invisible things like those are those
are quite difficult and finding the
interface between what the charity wants
and what's actually possible with the
available data can be difficult and you
have one group of people that understand
what is possible with the technology and
another group that understand the sector
and the needs and so you have to find
the interface ER and tied into that is
that communication is is much much more
important than technology so we we're
not really interested in developing a
fancy solution right we just want we
want to make a difference that's the
idea if you Duncan something you know
well that it's important to speak to
your audience and we have a strict no
jargon policy and the rule of thumb is
don't say plea by you to anyone unless
they said it to you already and yeah you
have one group of people that don't know
what API stands for and another group
that don't know what SDG stands for they
don't know what SDG stands for
sustainable development goals it's
obviously it's quite important and yet
often a project can tank just because
two sides aren't speaking the same
language and anyone's done any
interdisciplinary work at all we'll know
that I think finally yet it's important
to work with not four so again we we're
not interested in creating a fancy data
science solution you do get to do that
sometimes and that's that's fun but the
main motivation is making an impact
changing a behavior persuading someone
to provide funding or something
and if the other side if the the social
partner is not involved in the process
from the start then you'll likely end up
building a vanity project that's
something that's flashy and you're happy
with but that will not get used you know
you might dump a load of code in a
github repo but they don't know they
don't have anyone who knows how to code
and they won't understand it so and yet
even worse than that if you're not
careful you can actually end up doing
harm if you're not very rigorous with
your analysis and if you make
assumptions that don't actually apply to
the social sector you can end up giving
very poor misleading advice and the
sensitive nature of the data that you're
handling into that can be very damaging
so there's not a great answer to that
but we think that involving a
stakeholders right from the beginning
and as heavily as possible making sure
that there is a stakeholder partner
somebody in the organization is
dedicated to it from the start is really
important yeah that's about it I think
get involved come along we have data
does coming up and there's one in
Newport which is a little bit of a trick
that's really important one homelessness
and domestic violence charities and
there's another data live here at
Bloomberg in July which should be really
great keeping out on a meetup page if
you're interested we'd love to have you
a lot so data data kind in the UK has
two employees everyone else is a
volunteer and they're great employees to
be fair they get like the communication
is also amazing and but you know some
other colleges yeah yeah so yeah come
and be a part of it please we'd love to
have you and this is us so get in touch
get involved this is our Twitter thingy
and this is the meetup so like I said we
do have quite a lot of mid ups we will
have meetups where we talk about other
projects that we've done we have miracle
we give you kind of you know results of
products that we've just done for that
you can kind of know what we're up to
regularly and then we've got kind of
slightly more you know kind of general
meetups talking about stuff like you
know ethics in data analysis on data
science and all that kind of stuff
ah and this is our URL so yes we've
we've left kind of quite a bit of time
for questions
hoping that some of you have anything to
ask us although if you don't then you
know fine too but yeah so it's
we're really kind of hoping to get a lot
of people involved and again it's like
there are a lot of ways that you can get
involved with us it doesn't have to be
so doing like you know it's being
necessary data ambassador for did a dive
or whatever there's lots of other things
that we've got and we've got a growing
number of volunteers so but you know
join join the crowd and yeah do you have
any questions about either what we've
said or what we haven't said yes you
might yeah
[Applause]
morning I'm just wondering why with the
a lot of people in the commercial sector
use data science for marketing
applications why the blanket no for fuel
projects I think it's mainly a question
of volunteer motivation because it
really doesn't feel very different
marketing to fundraise for a charity
compared with fundraising or you know
selling stuff for another organization
is it's fairly out of the box thing and
that's one of the easier things for
charities to get other commercial
organizations to do for them so we
prefer to try and focus on more
interesting problems basically that's a
reasonable question but I think I think
it's also because that what we want to
get out of it is I mean obviously that
our primary kind of clients are are the
charity but we do want volunteers to get
involved in something that they think is
contributing to social good and I think
that's kind of important and if you're
just doing something that thing or now
this kind of marketing campaign is going
to be more effective it just doesn't
kind of fill it as if you've really saw
the real problem there as if you even
kind of really tackled it so I think
we're really trying to kind of stay on
the side of what what has an impact
input in the world as opposed to just
for the charity that's quite important
well the questions
so this question is kind of twofold so
one you had that kind of hundred and
thirty six thousand figure yeah what was
the kind of confidence interval of
addiction into around that I don't
remember off the top of my head but it
was I mean it was something that we were
kind of quite content with because we
did we worried I mean actually the
nineteen thousand one was slightly less
confident and we can only find it I can
I can look that up for you we add on
remember you need a question kind of
related to that is I mean that kind of
analysis is something that you need to
get right you could have quite a lot of
statistical rigor and you've got to
really know what you're doing which I'm
sure you guys do how do you vet your
volunteers or how do you make sure that
the people that your science projects
are kind of qualified and not going to
overconfident cuz you can get you can
get a dunning-kruger effect with some
has done a couple of courses in AI on on
Coursera yeah and do a project and they
say something but it might be completely
wrong so how do you make sure that it
happen so so we don't set the volunteers
but we do there is kind of sorting that
does occur kind of fairly naturally when
you have a group of let's say 50 people
working on a project and you know like
you you wouldn't just manage to [ __ ]
your way through it I mean and also you
know they're in that in that my specific
project it was something like maybe ten
really committed people who actually
carried out afterwards and those were
all people who were either kind of very
very good coders and all very good
decisions and we actually had I mean we
also knew who was on there right I mean
I guess we never kind of got to the
point where we had somebody with all you
know they don't really have the skills
they don't really know what they're
doing because actually like to the
leading kind of people who were working
on the statistical side had a kind of
very strong credentials and they were
working you know with that kind of stuff
as part of the day job and you just kind
of you just going to trust this I mean
to be fair instead what happened to us
that we've had a situation where we
thought that the person involved didn't
really know enough I think that we have
a very fast kind of array of skills and
we have some some sometimes hot people
during there that we don't who are not
necessarily very skilled but they're you
know they're here to learn and they kind
of stand on the fire and kind of get
involved in in things in a kind of more
you know kind of inter learning as a
runner in a running position and you do
notice this and we've never seen people
kind of basically fortunate but I guess
I guess that's Bessemer explain in
I don't mean assembly happen I don't
know happen in your project expert you
know it's not I agree I think something
we're we're after
yeah yeah it's partially self selecting
and partially there are lots of pairs of
eyes on any interesting results so there
is enough expertise in the room between
the ambassadors and the really skilled
volunteers that come along to hopefully
to provide sufficient checks and balance
yeah but also I mean a thing that was
important with that project was that be
such a data analyst from from the
charity was there for the entire two
days and she was very very involved and
so if there was anything that kind of
seemed like it it sounded right from a
kind of statistical point of view but it
just didn't really make any sense at all
from somebody who was actually involved
it on the terrain you know that she was
going to providing a lot of checks and
balances on that and this is also kind
of going back to the point I was making
earlier which is that as long as we keep
people who actually am who have the kind
of proper expertise of the domain
involved you can't really get it
completely wrong because it's not I
we're very careful to not just kind of
like dump a data science solution on
something without understanding the
domain and obviously we have some
understanding of it but it's reality
that people like that kind of data
analyst whose day-to-day job is to work
with the six related to homelessness
involve them then that kind of provides
a very good kind of you know a check and
balance at a point is our Laurie one one
more question for anybody else Oh
thank you for the talk connect it to the
early question actually he seems to be a
lot of risk in the sense that you called
it a figure and then you'll set the
point that ended up using that up to you
for most of their presentations or for
publicity
yeah so I realize how you guys just
mentioned the ethics of algorithms and
data science on the commercial side but
I guess that applies to not just
commercial slide what to you guys as
well my guess that betting site is
really quite crucial yeah and I guess
there's some danger of being I mean yeah
I mean there's a countability involving
we are we are accountable for this I
mean this is a figure that we are
accountable for and we stand by it and
we've got you know we try and I mean
it's always very hard to get people when
they're crunching away doing today's to
document everything they do but we are
we literally have people who just go
around everyone at the eyes documenting
are you documenting so we are we are
making sure that every you know that the
code the code is open anybody can check
it but also all the assumptions that are
made are documented so we're I mean a
lot of people during the project and not
necessarily the data time since they're
going to be other people behind who
actually check that and you know go
around with a note file and say okay
what assumption did you make when you
did this miss not which you know it's
something that that you kind of need in
those instances so so yeah but you're
right I mean there is accountability and
it we are aware of it you know an
association something like this but so
but we are you know which checks in
closet yeah no stops well thank you very
much every Charlie big round of applause
thank very much
[Applause]
[Music]